welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and no matter
how many times I watch the MCU there's
always something new that I noticed
after the success of our Avengers
endgame breakdown I thought I'd take a
closer look infinity war to discuss some
of the insane details in it that you may
have missed the movie is filled to the
brim with amazing little Easter eggs
callbacks to other films and thematic
devices that enrich in the world and in
my opinion make it the best movie in the
MCU throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking down some of the most obscure
details and hopefully helping you to
appreciate the film in a new light there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
got dusted during the snap and somehow
haven't managed to see the film yet then
I highly suggest that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for videos like this every day now let's
get into our breakdown of insane details
you missed in Avengers infinity war ok
so infinity war opens immediately after
the events of Thor Ragnarok with the
sanctuary 2 ravaging the is Guardian
refugee ship the distress call itself is
sent out by Kenneth Branagh who directed
the first Thor film and this is a nice
little vocal cameo by the actor and
director as for the scene itself on the
surface it seems pretty straightforward
but there's actually an amazing bit of
trivia here that not only shows the
matically what the movie is about but
also how darkness operates you may have
noticed that the ship is in fact torn in
two and from dual Ragnarok it looks like
it's being split directly down the
middle the side that we join has been
completely slaughtered by than us in his
forces whereas we know from avengers
endgame that the side with Valkyrie and
Korg on got away unharmed during
infinity war we discovered that Thanos
rides throughout the galaxy going planet
to planet and wiping out half of the
light that lived there the other half
are allowed to live and even in the
opening of the movie this aesthetic
remains it also pretty much gives away
the ending and shows that half of all
life will be wiped out and it's an
amazing way to start the film that
echoes throughout it during the opening
Heimdall sends Bruce to dr. strange but
how did he know to send the character
there well he didn't he
actually sent Brewster the time stone
rather than the Wizards this is the
place that he needed to be in order to
save time so that the group wouldn't
waste it needlessly looking for the
stone we get confirmation of this in the
film when Thor says at the time and mine
stone is safe on earth and thus Heimdall
has likely been keeping an eye on its
location we saw in Ragnarok that Doran
Heimdall can communicate telepathically
and I believe that Heimdall was going to
send off first
however the god of thunder told him to
send hulk instead it's very possible
that Thor could have given the character
permission to carry this out and this is
why the to look at one another and why
Thor has such an expression it all has
met dr. strange at this point and thus
he knows that the time stone is there
and that is where Hulk needs to go also
Heimdall dies with his eyes open and as
we know from the rest of the MCU he was
a keen watch here thus this is a fitting
death from here Thanos goes out on his
mission and the Loki tells the character
he will never be a god there were
actually a lot of similarities between
his quest and the Bible firstly God
created the world in six days and on the
seventh he rested this is similar to the
NAS who collects six stones and like God
he rests after completing his task the
Christian religion itself came in and
pretty much wiped out the older ones
such as Norse mythology and this is
exemplified by Thanos killing Loki and
destroying Thor in the introduction
Ragnarok was seen as the apocalypse of
the old gods and now that this has
happened
Thanos is free to come in and usher
something new Don Auster's and see
himself as destroying the universe he
sees his moves as creating something new
in the film Thanos and Gomorrah traveled
to vara Mia in order to achieve the soul
stone this has many parallels to the
sacrifice of Isaac which centered around
God testing Abraham by making him
sacrifice his only son like the NAS
Abraham climbed to the top of a mountain
with his child in order to prove his
faith and no one angel stopped this
sacrifice from happening God realized
that Abraham's love for him was true
this heavily mirrors the movie however
where Danice diverts from it is that he
actually sacrifices gomorrah the name
gomorrah itself is a reference to sodom
and gomorrah which were to ill fated
cities in the bible when Thanos finally
does carry out the snap we see those
turned to dust
which to me is also an
- the phrase ashes to ashes dust to dust
which is often used in Christianity also
I've noticed throughout most of the MCU
that Black Panther States something
ironic at some point for example in
Black Panther he states he never freezes
then ends up on ice he tells the Calle
that this is no place to die before
passing away and before the Battle of
Wakanda he proudly states that Thanos
will have nothing but dust in blood
which air is pretty much what then
ascends up gang another interesting
thing about people turning to Durst
happens with spider-man's death on
average all of the characters take less
than four seconds to pass away however
spider-man takes almost 40 seconds to
disintegrate and it is possible that
this is due to his healing factor his
spidey sense could have also warned him
in advance and this is why he stumbles
around beforehand his arm begins to turn
to dust initially and then he slumps
down showcasing that his body was trying
to repair the damage but it just got too
much for the character his appearance in
the movie is quite poetic as not only as
the character introduced through his
spidey sense but it's also how he goes
out infinity war also has a massive
theme of sacrifice laced throughout it's
when vision Office's life in order to
destroy the mind stone cap says we don't
trade lives this shows that there is a
cost with winning and in order to attain
victory you often have to lose something
Donis of course does end up winning but
he had to sacrifice Gamora in order to
do this and in the final exchange with
his daughter we get a sense of regret
from the character from his statement
that it cost everything the Avengers do
end up winning in endgame but it's at
the loss of Black Widow and Tony Stark's
life and this theme lets you know that
we always have to give something up in
order to win whilst these are all quite
thematic overarching details there are
actually a lot of minor things as well
that add a lot to the movie before
Ironman creates a weapon using
nanotechnology you can see the selection
pop up in the bottom of his helmet this
happens throughout the movie at several
points and shows his thought process
before the programming is carried out
when he goes to suit up for the first
time we actually see him remove his
glasses and then these disappear once
the suit comes over him indicating that
they too are made of nanotech
you can see the scales and the Captain
America's outfit which would of course
come to be fully on the surface and
Avengers endgame the first thing that
I'll say is is that he knows what it's
like to lose and that it turns the legs
to jelly this sets up the ending of
Avengers endgame as in that when he
realizes that he's been defeated the
first thing he does is sit down is
seating at the end of the film is also
carried across to the sequel from his
positioning and also the way that the
camera pans across we can also see his
armor in the bottom corner which we
would come to see from the front in
Avengers end game when Doctor Strange
fights Dan asks the character Ames to
pull a gauntlet off and creates mirror
versions of himself
Thanos activates the soul stone to
destroy this and this is why we see his
ethereal form in front of the character
before the spell collapses when Thanos
is speared through the chest by storm
breaker just before he disappears we can
see a slight glimmer of green which
indicates that the time stone saved his
life from this fatal wound this isn't
the only moment that the time stone
saved someone's life as it brings vision
back from the dead and also potentially
Captain America captor a massive punch
to the head from Thanos that likely
killed him however in reversing time the
character would have been brought back
to life that's a fan theory but it also
explains how cap was able to survive
such a blow we also see the Hulkbuster
get caught in some rocks and it would be
impossible to climb out of this without
severely damaging the suit however we
can see the Hulkbuster fixed at the end
and this adds a lot of weight to the
theory that the time stone reversed
everything when reversing time at Thanos
rotators hand counterclockwise which we
saw happen in Doctor Strange
dr. Strange's handshake throughout the
film which carries over from a solo
movie this trembling was repeated in
endgame and nurse it's become a
character trait the members of the Black
Order all have names that link to black
as well have any more
Corvus glaive Proxima midnight and cull
obsidian so ebony midnight obsidian and
Corvis the loki says that we have a Hulk
there's no way you missed that one
but Loki does call himself olinson and
this is a callback to Ragnarok in which
Odin greeted Thor and Loki as his sons
before dying
clearly he forgave Loki and now Loki was
ready to once more embrace the family
and announce him
as a member Toni mentions naming his and
peppers child Morgan which would come to
pay off an in-game as the name of their
daughter he also still carries the exact
same phone that Captain America gave him
at the end of civil war this is for
emergencies only or if he just wants to
join the wats up group or something
throughout the film
they'll Danis wishes to commit genocide
he's also extremely honorable and sticks
to his word he doesn't really seem to
kill anyone unless completely necessary
and at several points he bargains with
characters and doesn't Negin his end of
the deal
low-key exchanges the tesseract for
Thor's life and Thanos does actually
spare him though he does also blow the
ship up Gamora takes an austere varam
ear so that nebula can live and Doctor
Strange also trades the time stone with
the mad Titan in exchange for Tony's
life so yeah not a bad guy the fight
with Proxima midnight in Black Widow
both end in a similar way with the
Fallen being lifted into the air
initially at Edinburgh train station
this is done by the villain to escape
and later in the movie she is lifted
into the air by Scarlet Witch and killed
on top of that there are a ton of
references to other movies most notably
alien as when saving Doctor Strange
spider-man asks of Tony's seen aliens
before and then they kill more by
blasting amount into space this scene is
extremely similar to the death of the
alien queen even down to the positioning
more and it was definitely intentional
spider-man pays lip service to aliens
laying eggs in him like the chest
burster and also tony Holt has gone up
to drag his head immediately after this
which resembles the xenomorph in
Sigourney Weaver in havens 3 when
spider-man gets the iron spider suit
Ironman says Happy Trails and this is a
nod to die hard in which John McClane
said it after shooting hands out the
window there's a ton of things adding
into the movie and I'm even tempted to
do a second video because yeah the film
is just jam-packed anyway that's our
entire list and I had a blast making
this video and I hope you had fun
watching it obviously I loved hear your
thoughts on the tidbits so comment below
and let me know make sure you subscribe
to the channel for videos like this
every day and if you want something else
to watch them make sure you check out a
breakdown of the insane details that we
know isten avengers endgame it's one of
our best videos and is definitely worth
checking out if you
all Marvel trivia every month on the
15th we give away free blu-rays and all
you have to do to be in with the chance
of winning the Infinity Saga box set is
comment below leave a like and subscribe
with notifications on you want to
support the channel and get to see
content early then please consider
clicking the join button you can also
come chat to us on our discord server
which is gonna be linked below or a
definition whitey on Twitter those are
the best ways to keep up to date with
the channel so hopefully we see over
there very soon this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best I'll see you next
time
take care peace
[Music]